bienvenue à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition d'Europe
Hebdo présentée comme toujours au cœur
du Parlement européen à Bruxelles cette
semaine direction Madrid en Espagne ils
étaient au moins 100000 à défiler dans
les rues de la capitale de toutes
origines sociales de tous âges marche
organisé par podemos le parti issu du
mouvement des indigners leur chef le
voici Pablo Iglesias il veut en finir
avec les politiques d'austérité en
Espagne et plus largement en Europe le
parti espère remporter les élections
régionale au printemps prochain mais
d'abord l'actualité européenne la
bataille de la dette grecque est lancée
le nouveau Premier ministre grec cypras
promet de la renégocier pas si vite il
faudra discuter explication en image
il a commencé sa tournée européenne par
une visite chez son voisin chipriotte
accueilli avec les honneurs par le
président anastasiaad dont le pays est
lui aussi passé tout près de la faillite
il y a 2 ans Alexis cipras cherche le
soutien de ses partenaires européens le
jeune premier ministre élu sous la
bannière de Ciza a promis à son peuple
de renégocier la dette grecque un
fardeau de 315 milliards d'euros qui
paralyse le pays l'empêche
d'investir pour cette mission de tous
les dangers un homme est en première
ligne Yanis varoufakis nouveau ministre
grec des Finances il a été dépêché dans
les grandes capitales européennes à
Londres à Paris au côté de Michel Sapin
avec un seul et unique message mettre
fin au politiques
d'austérité il nous faut placer le
problème de l'autre côté de la table
pour trouver des solutions à ce problème
avec un objectif en tête la prospérité
pour le citoyen européen pas la
prospérité pour le citoyen grec français
ou portugais non la prospérité pour
chaque citoyen européen rendre à la
Grèce sa souveraineté économique c'est
le crédau du nouveau pouvoir grec alexis
cypras a promis de mettre dehors la
troyka ses haut fonctionnaires envoyé
par Bruxelles la Banque centrale
européenne et le FMI pour imposer des
coupes budgétaires drastiques au pays où
un jeune sur deux est au chômage alors
le ministre varoufakis prend les devants
il ne demande plus l'effacement de
l'ardoise grecque mais propose à ses
partenaires de troquer les prês accordés
à Athènes contre des obligations
perpétuelles qui seraient indexé sur la
croissance à venir une idée que le
nouveau pouvoir grec devra défendre
jusqu'à Berlin Angela Merkel est pour
l'instant intraitable sur le dossier le
bras de fer autour de la dette grecque
ne fait que
commencer
voyons jusquementement ce qu'en pense un
député allemand Andrea chois bonjourour
madame merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes membre du Parti
populaire européen débuté européen et
vous venez de la CDU le parti de
d'Angela Merkel est-ce que Angela Merkel
selon vous alors vous n'êtes peut-être
pas dans même sûrement dans dans sa tête
mais c'est c'est votre parti est-ce
qu'elle peut discuter en l'état actuel
des choses avec Alexis cypras et sur
quelle base surtout je je pense que
comme tous les autres États européens
nous avons su avec le plus grand respect
la décision du peuple grec du vote
dimanche dernier mais de notre point de
vue et on voit que c'est un point de vue
qui est largement partagé aussi dans les
états du sud de l'Europe c'est clair que
le nouveau le nouveau gouvernement grec
peut proposer de nouvelles choses mais
sur la base des décisions qui ont été
prises dans le passé c'est-à-dire celle
de la c'estd que nous sommes prês non
c'est-à-dire que d'après ce que j'ai lu
dans les journaux tout le monde est prêt
en Europe à aider afin d'arriver à cette
prospérité pour le citoyen européen qui
n'est pas un citoyen grec seulement mais
aussi un citoyen par exemple cypriote et
le Chypre a prêté à la Grèce 110
millions dans un moment très difficile
pour ce petit pays et ce petit pays et
les citoyens là ne veulent pas perdre
leur argent et je pense c'est un un fait
qu'il faut respecter aussi vous dites
que les choses se sont retournées c'est
maintenant des pays du Sud qui eux-mêmes
s'indignent finalement de de qu'on
accorderait des avantages particuliers à
la Grèce c'est ça que vous non mais
c'est ce que je j'observe c'est que le
ministre des Finances italien le
ministre des Finances français le
ministre des Finances en Espagne le
ministre des Finances en Chypre et je
pourrais ajouter d'autres exemples
disent tout on est ouvert pour des
propositions grecques mais on n'est pas
là pour laisser de côté de l'argent que
nous avons prêté à la Grèce dans un
moment critique pour nous aussi je pens
c'est la ligne des européennes et on va
voir ce que ça va donner la visite du
ministre du Premier ministre cypras ici
à Bruxelles aujourd'hui on va voir vous
dites que c'est en tout cas qu'il y a un
changement de la part de ces pays qui
étaient plutôt enclins à pratiquer le
relâchement budgétaire et vous mettez la
France dans ce groupe des pays du Sud
non je pense je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut être très clair eu le but n'a
jamais été l'austérité c'est un peu faux
dans le dans la dans le commentaire le
but a été d'arriver à des réformes
structurelles justement le dit hein
l'austérité c'est lui qui oui c'est lui
qui le disent mais de notre point de vue
on a fait des réformes pour arriver
exactement à cette prospérité pour tous
les citoyens européennes et
malheureusement on na pas encore tranché
toute la al pourquoi c'est pas efficace
pourquoi est-ce que ça ne produit pas
ces ces fruits ces politiques
d'austérité beaucoup d'économistes le
disent et même les États-Unis le disent
oui ça c'est ça c'est un débat difficile
de notre point de vue ces réformes
structurelles n'ont pas été menées à
fin je pourrais vous donner des exemple
les un certain nombre de mesures qui ont
été présentées au début traînent depuis
des mois et c'est des des mesures qui
peut-être font mal au début mais très
rapidement après citiez un exemple pour
comprendre l'exemple le plus positif je
dirais c'est que le le la flexibilité du
droit de travail en Grèce a été
finalement achevée et on a déjà vu les
premiers effets positifs et à ce
moment-là peut-être c'était pas très
bien organisé à ce moment-là le vote en
Grèce est en train de retourner tout en
en avant ça serait un grand problème
nous la Grèce a fait un grand pas en
avant et on on peut l'indiquer avec des
analytiques économiques et donc je pense
il faut se baser sur ces réformes là et
pas les mettre en question alors Alexis
cipras doit persuader ses partenaires et
notamment Angela Merkel on le disait les
négociations s'annoncent serrées je vous
propose d'écouter le point de vue de cet
économiste allemand on se retrouve juste
après
les prochaines semaines seront
captivantes on va voir jusqu'à quel
point les pays européens seront prêt à
faire des concessions et la position
allemande sera décisive à quel point
Angela Merkel sera--elle prête à changer
d'orientationicht gouvernement allemand
Andre peut alors peut-être pas changer
politique l' bien compris fixé sur le
cap unique de l'austérité mais est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir quand même une
inflexion vu ce nouveau contexte
européen je pense qu'il faut être
clairement dire il faut il faut
clairement dire que c'est pas une
position que l'Allemagne peut changer
elle-même unilatéralement c'est
l'eurozone qui a pris des décisions
c'est l'eurozone donc tous les
États-membres absolument c'est tous les
ministres des finan de tous les pays de
l'Eurozone qui ont dit on veut aider à
la Grèce c'est tous les pays de
l'Eurozone qui ont mis de de l'argent
sur la table donc c'est pas l'Allemagne
seule qui peut dire aujourdh bien sûr
nous voulons nous voulons être
constructifs nous voulons arriver dans
une situation dans laquelle la Grèce
peut rester facilement dans la zone euro
mais au même moment il faut aussi dire
que les réformes doivent être menées à
fin en Grèce en même temps vous disiez
que ce nouveau gouvernement grec on peut
lui accorder le bénéfice du du doute le
ministre de l'Économie monsieur
varoufakis a des idées il propose
notamment d'échanger donc les les prêts
consentis à ce pays contre des
obligations perpétuelles pour vous vous
c'est une idée qui peut être acceptable
ça je trouve le positif dans ce contexte
c'est qu'il a déjà changé le langage
qu'il a utilisé juste après les
élections donc on voit qu'il y a une
adaptation à la réalité je je m'en
félicite c'est une bonne nouvelle
néanmoins il faut maintenant regarder de
plus près la situation actuelle la
France en tant que pays paye beaucoup
plus de service à la dette que la Grèce
si on si maintenant on devrait expliquer
aux élect acteur français de payer
encore plus d'argent pour la Grèce pour
que ce pays-là paye encore moins de
servicees à la dette ça serait difficile
à expliquer donc il faut rester en
balance dans T ces questions dans toutes
ces questions et j'espère que l'eurozone
le le Conseil des ministres de
l'eurozone peut y arriver en
consentement avec le ministre des
Finances grec dans les premiers dans les
prochains jours quand il vont se
rencontrer ça va se dérouler dans les
jours qui suivent vous êtes plutôt
optimiste et sur quelle base voyez-vous
comme toujours mais s'il y avait un
compromis ce serait sur quoi une un
réchelonnement de la dette puisqu'on
parle d'un compromis la Grèce devra
d'ici financer les dernières dettes dans
l'an
2057 c'est déjà assez loin si c'est
maintenant 58 ou 59 ça va pas changer
grand chose donc la priorité c'est de
nouvelles réformes par exemple un
programme de lutte contre la trouve la
base je trouve la base madame gr la base
madame devrait être ce qu'on a discuté
avec les anciens gver gouvernement et si
le nouveau gouvernement veut améliorer
ça en Grèce d'accord et l'Europe veut
aider à la Grèce mais on peut pas dire
on peut pas expliquer à un électeur en
France à un électeur en Espagne que
celui-là doit maintenant encore payer
plus pour la Grèce bien que ces pays ont
déjà contribué largement à aider la
Grèce enclair si Alexis cypras refuse
demain de continuer à travailler avec la
troyka l'Europe effondé à dire et bien
dans ce cas on ne lui donne pas l'argent
non mais je pense vous avez déjà
mentionné le fait que monsieur cipras a
aussi changé un peu de langage euh je
pense un certain nombre de facteurs ont
été euh ont été changé dans les derniers
jours et pour cette raison je et je
pense au moins moi-même je pense qu'on
peut arriver dans une situation où le
peuple grec peut voir à nouveau que
l'Europe veut aider à la Grèce nous
avons le plus grand intérêt que la Grèce
reste en Europe nous avons le plus grand
intérêt que ça se fait comme prévu mais
on peut pas changer les règles le jeu et
comme toujours en Europe ce sera le
compromis qui va se dessiner merci
beaucoup Andr ch pour votre commentaire
sur cette actualité européenne chargé
puisqu'il se passe aussi des choses en
Espagne le mouvement podémos monte dans
les sondages une marche a rassemblé plus
de 100000 personnes à Madrid nous avons
pris le pou de la manifestation et
essayer de comprendre pourquoi beaucoup
de gens se tournent vers podemo c'est un
reportage signé Elsa mondagava Caroline
motte et Véronique
lendolphini
la veille de la grande marche de Madrid
les militant de podo s'active pour
certains c'est la première fois qu'il
s'implique autant dans un parti
politique Margarita 61 ans elle est
professeur aujourd'hui tous les par
Politi ont des histoires ils nous ont
rendu
méfiant nous avover
il n'y a pas d'autre parti qui m
convaincu podemos c'est l'espoir d'un
futur
meilleur podemos c'est un nouveau parti
fondé il y a un an en réaction à la
crise économique que traverse l'Espagne
depuis plusieurs années en a 56 ans il
est au chômage depuis 4 ans et vit avec
420 € par mois alors que son loyer
s'élève déjà à 500 € il doit compter sur
l'aide de ses proches et doit faire des
sacrifices je n'ai pas de quoi payer le
chauffage je ne l'allume pas alors qu'à
Madrid ces derniers temps il a fait
moins 2
degrés il en veut à l'Union européenne
et au gouvernement espagnol qui s'est
laissé imposer un plan d'austérité
drastique c'est une chose d'appartenir à
l'Union européenne de donner et de
recevoir CEN est une autre d'arriver à
une telle humiliation ne pas pouvoir
manger ne pas pouvoir se chauffer quand
il fait froid ici il nous expulse à 7h
du matin on pe pas per loyer même quand
on a des petits enfants les gens dorment
dans les parcs on est
humilié Miguel lui a une meilleure
situation pourtant il a fait 400 km pour
être présent à la marche du changement
médecin de famille son salaire a baissé
de 15% en quelques années mais il a
surtout vu l'état de la population se
dégrad
je pa par exemple ils sont de plus en
plus pauvres beaucoup n'ont pas de
travail et c'est difficile pour eux de
sortir juste 1 € pour des
médicament alors il se soignent mal et
ne guérissent pas
bien pour la première fois il se rend à
une réunion publique de
podemos je préfère essayer quitte à me
tromper si je me trompe en votant pour
le Parti socialiste ou la droite là je
m'en voudrai vraiment parce que je
serais complice de leur politique et ça
je ne peux pas me le permettre
le mouvement invite ses sympathisants à
se regrouper en cercle de discussion
pour s'exprimer échanger mais avant tout
faire remonter à la tête du parti des
propositions concrètes des cercles à
Madrid il y en a des dizaines Arthur y
participe régulièrement même s'il est
français il y a des Français des
Italiens des
Allemands on peut voter au municipal
mais pas donc aux autres élections mais
c'est pas ça qui pose problème on on vit
ici 6 mois et on sait qu'on peut tout de
suite participer la vie du quartier
donner notre avis faire des
projets voilà ça qui intéressant et
aussi donc il y a plusieurs Français
l'idée c'est aussi un peu d'essayer de
voir ce qu'on pourrait faire en France
on pourrait essayer de développer un peu
ce ce
modèle come en et les autres ils étaient
au moins 100000 à défiler à Madrid pour
la marche du 31 janvier pour les
manifestants c'était l'occasion
d'exprimer un RB et une volonté de
changement pour le parti podéos manière
de lancer la campagne pour les élections
de mai prochain la formation politique
est en tête des
sondages nous pouvons rêver nous pouvons
gagner deux invités nous ont rejoint sur
ce plateau pour discuter de ce phénomène
podemos deux invités espagnols avec nous
Véronica Lopé fontagier bonjour vous
êtes député européenne membre du PPE qui
regroupe les par de droite et de centre
droit et à vos côté Ines Ayala sender
bonjour vous êtes également député
espagnol membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrate on va pas faire
de débat de politique intérieure
espagnole on neesse de comprendre ce
phénomène podéos comment expliquez-vous
ce succès de ce mouvement qui a à peine
1 an bon je crois que on le voit un peu
dans le reportage il y a eu le
mécontentement la crise économique les
mesures que les gouvernement on été
obligé de prendre pour sortir de la
prise on est en train petit à petit
d'améliorer la situation il y a la
croissance en Espagne mais évidemment la
situation était difficile et il y a une
la population a été très mécontente des
mesures qui ont été pris mais je crois
que ça a été nécessaire et on n pas
d'autres moyens en ce moment est-ce que
vous avez la même analyse que votre cèg
moi je pense que vraiment on a eu une
situation où à niveau européen on a on n
pas su donner une réponche pas seulement
aux jeunes ou qu'on voit dans le ou aux
personnes âgées qui ont perdu leur
boulot mais notamment en général à la à
la croissance et au développement de
l'emploi en Europe c'est l'Union
européenne qui est directement
responsable de la monté de parou parce a
oui parce que ils ont comment dire on a
imposé et d'une façon on le voit très
clair dans la brèche nord-sud qui s'est
ouverte et comment les pays du Sud on
ont été contraints à des mesures des des
des
des mesures structurelles disons imposé
par la Troya et par notamment par le
gouvernement de droite allemande et qui
ont mis euh les les les les gens dans
une situation impossible mais on ajoute
à ça que les gouvernement comme disait
ma ma collègue le gouvernement de droite
en Espagne a aidé encore avec des
mesures supplémentaires par exemple via
des privatisations d'hôpitaux des
privatisation
de l'éducation et ça a encore appauvri
en plus les les Espagnols alors le
leader eglésias dit c'est la faute des
deux partis dominants en Espagne
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez qui
n'ont
pasond que on soit censé ce n'est pas la
faute de l'Europe s'il y a une crise
économique les pays beaucoup ont vécu
dans l'Espagne avait vécu en au-dessus
de leurs moyens il y a un moment il faut
payer les dettes et il faut faire les
restrictions nécessaires pour continuer
pour ne pas être en en faillite euh et
je crois que on a fait ce qu'on a dû
faire et je crois qu'en ce moment il y a
5 ans il y a 6 ans l'Espagne était le
parti qui le pays qui créa le plus de
problèmes à l'Europe et en ce moment on
voit la croissance on voit que les y a
qu' y a eu une réussite qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé avec podemos c'est évident
que euh il y a des mécontentement avec
raison et euh c'est facile un P un parti
h
ou des personnes qui disent qu'ils vont
tout arranger qu'on va pas payer la
dette qu'on va augmenter les salaire
qu'on va moins travailler on va pas
payer d'impôt les gens sont contents
mais il faut réellement savoir quelle
est la réalité et ça c'est pas la
réalité il faut pas mentir aux électeurs
alors est-ce que vous pensez que podémos
est-ce que son programme est
réaliste commencer je suis pas d'accord
qu'on a vécu au-dessus de de la capacité
puisqueen 2007 l'Espagne n'avait presque
pas de déficit public il y avait pas de
dette publique la dette était énormément
privée parce que tant les entreprises
comme les les foyers
étai comment dire poussés par les
banques et là je pouroudrais dire de
noms qui ne sont pas seulement des
banques espagnoles mais aussi des
banques par exemple c'est fa des banqu
c'est on a aidé les banques pas la on a
absolument poussé les gens mais que vous
pouvez pas imaginer à prendre des
hypothèques sur des pas seulement sur
pour payer leur leur euh appartement
pour vivre mais aussi le meublet le VO
la voiture bon c'est c'est ça a été
vraiment une une une course à à
l'endettement privé et quand la crise
est venue évidemment les banques et ça a
été une décision prise à niveau européen
pas seulement au niveau espagnol pas du
tout on est responsable aussi de cette
situation absolument par la politique
d'austérité et par la politique de
mettre en avance les les problèmes des
banques qui étaient qui avaient endetté
la population et les entreprises et du
coup ils voulaient voilà avoir leur
bilan nickel et ça ça a été tout d'un
coup on a rachetter la dette privée
s'est convertie par imposition de
l'Europe en dette publique et du coup
voilà on était dans une situation
impossible comme euh comme pays et on a
vu la la la prime de risque monté Moné
aussi euh vous savez que la prime de
risque a une un bilan avec euh le
comment dire la la monnaie le l'euro
mais aussi les la Bundesbank de façon
que on a eu vraiment une position qui a
dont l'Europe a été responsable de ne
pas immédiatement comme ça a été aux
États-Unis on l'a vu très clairement de
pousser pour la croissance et pour
l'investissement rapidement comme c'est
le cas quand il y a une crise de T les
États-Unis sont sortis déjà nous on
sommes encore dans l'indigence vous
allez répondre à votre collègue est-ce
que le gouvernement espagnol aurait pu
faire un peu plus pour ceux qui n'ont
qui n'ont pas grand-chose aujourd'hui
non le gouvernement espagnol est en
train et a fait beaucoup de choses quand
on a pris le gouvernement je voulais pas
rentrer dans une discussion de politique
intérieure mais ma collègue mais
m'oblige à quand on commence à trouver
un pays qui est pratiquement en faillite
il faut penser que nous on étit des pays
qui on voulait intervenir le parce que
la la situation était difficile
maintenant c'est ça s'est amélioré on a
fait des réformes très importantes on
est en train de créer des des emplois on
n'a pas descendu les pensions des des
personnes des qui étaient à la retraite
on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu et la
réussite je crois va se voir dans le
temps dans le temps dans bientôt alors
en attendant Pablo glisia excusez-moi je
voudrais dire aussi l'Europe n'est pas
coupable personne ne vous empêche de de
gestionner bien les choses et de
évidemment c'est ce que dit Marine Le
Pen c'est ce que disent tous les partis
anti-européens
de tout je suis pas du tout d'accord
alors une décision d'une Europe d'une
Europe où une majorité ont décidé
deopter par la par l'austérité et nous
comme parti on é c'est pour ça qu'on est
en train de de sortir de la crise alors
mais mais justement il y a la mor pas
qui disent les experts en tout cas il il
y a il y a en tout cas la montée de de
de ces partis cyisa en Grèce podemos en
Espagne Pablo eglesias lui croit en sa
bonne étoile élu député européen ici en
mai dernier il a maintenant un programme
pour son mouvement résumé comme cela
écoutez le vent du changement commence à
souffler en Europe en moins d'une
semaine voilà ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement
grec électricité gratuite pour 300000
familles qui ne pouvaient plus payer
arrêt des privatisations des ports de la
Compagnie générale d'électricité et de
aéroports
couverture sociale pour tous les
citoyens reconnaissance de la
nationalité grecque pour tous les
enfants peu importe la couleur de
leuréadmission des professeurs
àed qui a dit que nous ne pouvions rien
faire qui a dit qu'un gouvernement ne
pouvait pas changer les
choses alors votre réaction sur toutes
ces mesures là est-ce que c'est
totalement utopique ou est-ce que ça
peut être mis en place non c'est pas
en principe ce sont des mesures à
l'interne de la Grèce mais il parl pas
et ça c'est la grande question sur le
programme en relation avec l'Europe ou
silissa a dit déjà qu'il veut pas s'en
sortiragne et la Grèce est-ce que pour
vous on peut comparer les les deux pays
l'Espagne n n'est pas la Grèce ça c'est
clair ni par les passés parce que la la
situation fiscale de la Grèce n'a rien à
voir avec la la capacité la situation
fiscale en Espagne puisque on a comment
dire c'était le gouvernement sociiste au
commencement des années 80 qui a
organisé le système fiscal en Espagne et
voilà c'est d' ri avir la capacité des
comment dire les les jeunes les jeunes
qui sont préparés tous les institutions
qui qui s'organisent malgré des
situations difficiles mais là ce que je
trouve que c'est la question et là on
est dans le Parlement européen c'est
quelle est la position de par rapport à
la comment dire à la position de
l'Espagne en
Europe dit il a changé très vite d'avis
par rapport à à la dette à comment on
dira sortir ou pas de l'euro et ceter
est-ce que c'est un danger ce Tye de
parti pour la démoc quand vous parlez
vous dites le programme de podon c'est
pas un programme ça ce sont des promesse
mais il faudrait savoir avec quoi ils
vont payer qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
Grèce avec quoi vont payer la Grèce avec
les dettes qu'ils ont avec les Français
avec les Espagnols avec les Allemands on
va devoir donner plus d'argent ils vont
pas rendre l'argent demandz au chôurs
français au chômeurs espagnol qu'est-ce
qu'il pensent en Espagne on calcule que
déjà l'argent qu'on a prêté c'est à peu
près 600 € par
personne on peut faire des promesses
comme ça mais il faut payer les dettes
aussi c'est responsable pour vous comme
comme idée c'est pas non mais ça c'est
c'est très joli de dire tout le monde va
tout le monde est gentil et tout va
aider tout le monde évidemment t les
partis on veut aider tout le monde mais
après il faut payer et là je ne parle
pas du tout de comment il va le faire
comment quel est le budget d'où il va
sortir l'argent et ça on n parle pas du
tout c'est pas un programme électoral et
d'ailleurs je crois que il sait qu'il ne
pourrait pas le faire et j'espère qu'il
ne gouvernera pas parce que si on est en
train de sortir de la crise ça serait
pour l'Espagne la catastrophe parce qu'à
ce moment-là on serait à nouveau au band
de l'Europe
rhe pour l'esagne et pour l'eope bon euh
en tout cas nous on est pour la
démocratie de façon que de la même façon
qu'on a accepté la situation en Grèce et
on a appuyé les résultats sans sans
mettre voilà c'est aux Espagnols le
moment venu de de de de de dire mais
c'est vrai que dans les élections un
danger pour la démocratie on appelle
directement au peuple cette forme de de
démocratie directe est-ce que ça ça non
mais c'est ils vont les espagnols vont
voter ils ont les droit à voter comme
comme partout ça veut dire on peut dire
le même du Front national en France
c'est et ils vont ils vont participer
dans dans les élections mais non je je
veux dire que c'est plutôt euh la façon
de de se présenter aux élections par
exemple en mai nous avons déjà les
élections locales régional et là pouréon
il il a pas voulu se présenter pour ne
pas tâcher en disant avec la gestion
cotidien du municipal du local qui est
la base de la gestion politique ils ont
dit ah non nous ne voulons pas entrer
dans ces élections on attend les grandes
élections où c'est comment dire plus
facile de faire seulement des promesses
et pas mettre vraiment jouer avec les
les la les besoins des gens et ne pas
mettre un programme où vraiment on on
t'oblige les quotidiens du local et du
régional est beaucoup plus dur et c'est
ça que pour moi c'est la grande question
pourquoi ils veulent pas se mettre
comment dire en égalité des chances avec
les reste de partis pour se présenter
aux élections locales avec leur euh logo
étiquette on verra bien jusqu'où
marcheront les les militants de de
podemos Merci à VOUS Ines Ayala suunder
et à vous Véronica Lopé fontagier
d'avoir été sur ce plateau pour n donner
cet éclairage vue d'Espagne très bonne
suite de programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires on se donne rendez-vous
la semaine prochaine ce sera Nora Amadi
bye